لكن في البداية كانت ابنتي هي التي أخبرتني
قال وصلت أمس من رحلة و
عرض الصور التي أخافتني كثيرا
لأنها واقعية للغاية
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كل شيء كل شيء عار تماما و
ما يثير القلق هو أنهم واقعيون للغاية
الصور التي في الحقيقة أنا فقط أحب ذلك
عند رؤيتها اعتقدت أنها كانت حقًا
ثم أنظر وأقول، أوه لا، إنها ليست هي.
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ثم أخبرتني ابنتي و
لقد علم المحادثة لأنه معي
تواصل عبر Instagram أكثر
لديه محادثة مع واحد من
الرجال حيث يقول نعم
هل يمكنك إعطاء بعض المال عن طريق الإجابة على سؤالي
البنت وليس الولد
يقول لا مباشرة ويرسل له
الصورة المونتاج الصورة
[موسيقى]
لتجنب الانتشار الذي أيضا
إنها جريمة يعاقب عليها بحوالي خمسة
سنوات في السجن
[موسيقى]
نحن نواجه موقفا، دعنا نقول ذلك
كل هذا هو وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الجديدة
الذكاء الاصطناعي للإنترنت يفتح
دعنا نقول الظروف الجديدة التي تسير
أن تكون قلقًا جدًا بشأن كل شيء
وأيضا في خلق الأخبار
خطأ شنيع